I think the decision making is a part of
the issue of assertiveness is always
thinking about assertiveness,
a home serving as he can be with other
people,
but you have to be assertive with
yourself and make personal decisions.
I know of a woman who takes somebody
else to go shopping with him because she
can't make a decision as to buy the pink
or the blue.
Right.
Back in my office,
I used to have a poster that showed a
dog standing between two fire hydrants
and the caption was decisions,
decisions and sometimes the decisions
that we are indecisive about hour of no
greater consequences than what I
remember in the Shul.
There was a whole argument at a meeting
from the the short organization about an
affair that they were going to have,
whether they shouldn't have the keyhole
with sugar or they can't hold without
sugar.
I mean these,
they said,
but there are decisions on life that are
much greater than that.
I mean,
you make the decision as to who you're
going to marry a decision,
what kind of professional you want,
what kind of job you want to.
A.
As a doctor,
I have to make a decision,
I'm going to treat the patient right
sometimes their decision,
um,
do,
do we take a chance on surgery?
What are the risks of surgery?
So there's all levels of decision making
first and we have to realize is we are
not always going to make the correct
decision,
right?
Only God can be right 100 percent of the
time I'm going to make wrong decisions,
but my decision making has to be a with
integrity,
right?
If I go to think about whether I should
operate on a patient or not,
it's not because how much I can collect
for the operation,
but what is the best thing for this
patient?
So,
uh,
first of all,
we have to realize that we are,
uh,
housed within a physical body that has
desires and it has impulses,
etc.
And that they may color our decision
making,
right?
We may not realize that sometimes we
were bribed,
right?
And the bribe is because we want things
to turn out a certain way and we don't
make the decision.
Um,
whAt is really right?
Because we see what is going to be
right,
what we want to be,
right.
So,
uh,
there was a,
one of the great facility rivers who was
asked by one of his followers,
how can I make good decisions?
So the rep,
he said,
did you ever watch the type walker?
He says,
the way a tightrope walker keeps his
balance is that he feels himself pulled
over to the one side,
he overcorrect spot leading to the other
side.
And that's how he keeps his balance.
He says,
when you have a desire to do something,
the first thing you ought to recognize
is most of the desires come from an
animalistic traits.
So the first thing you should do is
think as to why he should not do it
right?
And then he leaned over to that side
venue may make a decision.
Uh,
I think that we have to have self
confidence in our decisions and realize
I am capable of making decisions.
There are times when I have to ask
expertise that expert advice,
but given that ultimately the decisions
are mine.
And I also have to realize that not
making a decision is a decision,
but I've decided not to make a decision
and I have to realize that if I'm not
going to make decisions,
people,
other people aren't going to make them
for me,
right?
And the stations that other people are
going to make for me,
I much,
much Worse than this.
And then the worst decision that I can
make for myself because,
uh,
I have my,
my own interest that night.
Really,
most people know what's good for them.
So,
uh,
I think that making decisions means
getting the best possible information,
right?
And having self confidence.
I think it's appropriate to pray for
decisions,
right?
And that's for divine guidance and help
me make the right decision.
And then not to be shaken by the fact
that after we do the best we can,
that the decision may not work out the
way we want.
Right?
And not to see that a,
a decision that has poor consequences,
not disease.
That as a horrible failure on our part.
I always say our decisions are good or
bad.
Determined by how we made them.
Not what the consequences were.